an eleven-year-old girl has died after
getting into difficulty at a water park
skies iva bennett has the latest from
the park in berkshire
this is the water park here it's called
liquid leisure it's just outside windsor
as you can see it's closed today after
what happened yesterday afternoon but
staff have been arriving here and some
of them do appear quite upset
about what happened inside there's a
lake and on that there's a floating
obstacle course for that section
children
are required to wear life jackets but
life jackets aren't required on the
beach section of the lake and one
witness has told sky news today that
that's where the incident happened uh
the girl was apparently part of another
was part of a group celebrating another
girl's birthday they were swimming in
the deepest part of that that beach
section and the goal was apparently seen
going underwater but then she didn't
emerge
lifeguards were told
immediately responded rushed over to
help
members of the public were asked to call
out the girl's name staff here
apparently asked for their goggles asked
customers for their goggles so they
could use them and helps the search
underwater and help try and look for the
girl underwater emergency services were
also called that happened just before
four o'clock and there was police
ambulance crews fire services also
helicopters taking part in what they
describe
as an extensive search of the lake but
it wasn't until more than an hour later
that the girl this 11 year old girl was
eventually found she was rushed to
hospital nearby wexan park hospital but
it's there that she sadly died and
thames valley police have issued a
statement in which they praise
the members of the public who who tried
to help and save the girl
superintendent michael greenwood
said this is this has been an extremely
traumatic and upsetting incident for all
involved i'm aware that several members
of the public entered the lake shortly
after the girl got into difficulty but
were unable to locate her i would like
to commend them he says for their
courage and bravery
at the moment the girl's death is being
treated as unexplained but police have
launched an inquiry an investigation
into what happened
liquid leisure say they're helping with
that investigation but won't be
commenting any further only to say that
their thoughts and prayers are with all
of those affected by this tragic and
upsetting incident